ricardo hausmann is a venezuelan
economist teaching economic development
at harvard kennedy school he's been
speaking to our editor-in-chief manuela
caspar claridge at the world economic
forum meeting in davos
ricardo the german chancellor has asked
on oil producing countries to produce
more oil to dispense of russian oil how
realistic is this from your point of
view i think there's an interesting
agreement to be made
we need to separate opec from russia as
you know russia joined opec in december
2016 in a structure called opec plus
i think the basis of the bargain is the
following
the west is going to make sure that
russia gets no access to financial
markets that they get no access to oil
technology and that they get no access
to oil markets that's going to reduce
the ability for russia to invest in oil
and to maintain production
this is going to be good for
decarbonization so because what matters
for decarbonization is the reduction in
global oil production
but we need to decarbonize in a way that
assures energy security and energy
affordability
so we need opec to guarantee energy
security in a process in which the
market share of russia is going to
shrink and that's in the interest of the
saudis the emiratis and the other oil
producers so i think that that deal
should be on the table and i think they
should sit down to negotiate but how
long could this take i mean this would
take quite a while i guess
we're not in a hurry this is important
for the long term in the short term
the discussion in europe has been
completely derailed by the idea of
becoming independent from russia and to
embargo russian oil
this
may be good for europe in the medium
term to assure european security but
right now there's a war going on and you
want to harm russia so the way to harm
russia is not to embargo russian oil it
is to tax russian oil
today tomorrow immediately tax russian
oil that will imply that russian oil
will have to complete peat with saudi
oil in the european market and they will
have to be sold at the same price
controlling for quality
at the same price but the only problem
is that the russian price includes a tax
and the saudi price doesn't so saudi oil
would be cheaper obviously no so the
russian oil will have to go down in
price russia will have to give bigger
discounts we already see that the
discount between euros oil the russian
oil and and and brent the standard oil
the benchmark
used to be three dollars now it's thirty
dollars let's make it into sixty dollars
or seventy dollars and that's the way to
hurt poutine now
let's talk about in energy security in
european geosecurity uh you know in
december if you want but right now
there's a war going on in russia in in
ukraine and we need to reduce the cash
flow of mr putin and we do that with
taxing russian oil and then you can use
that money to rebuild ukraine
to subsidize consumers
to
help
ukrainian refugees whatever but ricardo
doesn't want change one depends then
dependency to the other
i think that in the long run
we need to decarbonize but we're not
going to decarbonize in
in a year that's why the target is 2050.
we need to assure that we get to 2015 at
zero but in in the meantime we need to
assure energy security and energy
affordability the world the atmosphere
doesn't care whose oil got burned
right but we care whose oil got burned
because
there are some countries that if they
sell oil and make a lot of money they
use that to attack other countries that
is a very expensive oil because you have
to count the cost of oil and your cost
of defense and your cost of
administering refugees and your cost of
helping the other country so russian oil
is the most expensive oil there is we
need to get rid of it but we will get
rid of it gradually
in the meantime we will tax it
cardio houseman from harvard kennedy
school speaking to manuela casper
claridge there